this is a production of cornell
university
it's pruning season and i wanted to show
you what the vine looks like before we
prune during prune and after pruning
so this is a pretty standard grapevine
here for the finger lids we're in a
riesling block
this is called a double geo or a two
tier flat bow system
so this was a cane pruned vine uh last
season
and so here's our first cane that comes
out this is another cane
came here
and then a cane here too
and from our canes we grew the shoots
right here these are some nice shoots
uh and on the shoots are buds
and so basically our fruiting zone
was right through here
so our our buds would have gone leaf
leaf
and then cluster cluster and you can see
where some clusters came off here
and then it would go up from there so up
above here this was all leaf area
our fruit was in here hidden in some
leaves
so now what we need to do
is prune these so that we are laying out
some canes again for this year
so i'm going to move up the row here
i prepared a vine and cut out a little
bit of the stuff around it so that you
can better see what we're doing
so here's a vine that i'm preparing for
pruning
so what we want to do is get rid of
these old canes
and we need to lay down new canes so
that they'll produce shoots this year
so we're going to look at what we have
that's going to be decent for laying
down
and in this case
this wood is quite poor i just snapped
it as i was bringing it around the wire
but it has a gray wood that's up here
and so that means that the cane is
basically dead or is in very poor shape
so this is not going to work to be a
cane to lay down there because none of
that is going to grow that's all gray
when you cut through there
so that's not going to work for me to
lay it down
so we're looking for something to lay
down here
i don't particularly want to use this
one for two reasons
one is that it's very thick in diameter
this is what we call bull wood
and we want something that's a little
more narrow
like this
uh the second reason is that this is
quite far out from this region that we
call the head of the vine
and if we use this one then we'll have
no fruit production along this area
so that's not great either so basically
there's nothing on this cane that i can
use so i'm going to cut it out we don't
need any of this down here
so i'm just going to get rid of some of
this
clean it up and get it out of here
and get rid of the rest of this cane too
you can see it actually entwines into
the neighboring vine
so
that's gone
and what we're gonna have to do is find
something else to lay down in its place
and in this case this
might be
a pretty decent choice
it's got some nice periderm as we would
say this nice brown wood along here and
would probably tie out reasonably well
here
it gets a little gray at the end but uh
it might be our best choice i think for
what's going to go along here
so for now
i'm gonna go like this
and get rid of this gray stuff at the
end
so that's one cane
now we need to lay out another cane
along this fruiting wire
this one looks not too bad uh
a little speckled
a little thicker than i would like
but we don't really have any good
options left here
so i'm gonna get rid of this
cut off this old cane
it's just easier to
get these out of the way by cutting
and that one's gone
and i think the plan is going to be to
lay this one down
got to get it through our catch wires
here
got a clip on our wires
so this one's clearly a little long it
goes into the next vine so i'm going to
snip that off there
so that will go down along that wire
this one
along here
so moving to the other side of the vine
we're looking for some killings to lay
down we've cut this one off already
we've got some nice uh gray wood here
that we know is not going to produce uh
very good buds or shoots it's actually
got some
spots from phomopsis
right along the cane here and so that is
probably why the cane is mostly dead
so in this case we're looking for two
canes that are close to the head of the
vine that we can lay down on these
fruiting wires
so let's see this one does not look too
bad
that one is gray at the top so that's
not going to be very good
and then this one gets out a little bit
far
so in this case i think this is probably
my best shot
i'll get this out of here
and so then i'll lay this one down along
here
now we need a cane for on the other side
uh neither of these is perfect again
that this one gets more gray towards the
top but this one is a little bit bigger
with longer internodes
so hard to decide exactly what to use
here i think i'd probably go for this
one
so in this case i'm going to cut this
off
get rid of all this
clean up this mess you can see this is
all dead wood it's had famous on it
this comes from the neighboring vine so
i'm gonna just cut this out of the way
here
and this here
is actually a really really long shoot
so we've left this one as a potential
trunk renewal so often our trunks will
get damaged from the cold
in the finger lakes region we normally
leave a couple of trunks so that we have
a backup if one gets damaged we've still
got another one
we've left this here in case we want to
replace one of the trunks in this case
it's not necessary there's no visible
damage here
having said that when there's cold
damage on the trunk it can often show up
a couple of years later
but this is actually this huge shoot
that comes up and across here so i'm
going to get rid of this whole thing
cut it out of the way i'm going to leave
a bud down here though
so that we can use this as a potential
renewal again so the butt at the bottom
here will grow into another shoot that
will grow up and then if we want to
replace a trunk next year
we'll have that
so let me cut this out and i'll show you
what this is going to look like
so i'm going to cut off the top of this
because it's longer than we need
so this is going to be our cane for this
side
and then this one again is longer than
we need
and it's really big here at the top
but this is going to be our cane that
wraps along this fruiting wire
right here
so this is a cane pruned vine now so
we've got our four canes one two three
four
and each of these has a series of nodes
on them right here and each node is a
bud
and these buds are going to grow into
shoots and those shoots are going to
produce group grapes this growing season
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu